les Français donneront-ils bientôt leur
avis dans les urnes c'est ce qu'on
envisagerait Emmanuel Macron en invitant
les chefs de parties le président tente
de dépasser les clivages cela pourrait
aboutir à un préférable le même jour les
électeurs pourraient s'exprimer non pas
sur une mais plusieurs questions par
exemple il voterait oui ou non sur un
projet de loi sur l'école les retraites
ou la proportionnelle
[Musique]
chaque camp va proposer ces sujets le
rassemblement national a déjà fait
savoir qu'il voulait un référendum sur
l'immigration si les républicains
l'arc républicain n'accepte pas le débat
si la gauche n'accepte pas ce débat
alors vous mettez plein de balles en
2027 un second tour entre
vous mettez plein de
Jean-Luc Mélenchon Marine Le Pen au
second tour
[Musique]
c'est un ministre au milieu du chaos
Eric Dupont-Moretti le visage fermé est
venu ce lundi constater les nombreux
dégâts dans le tribunal d'Aurillac des
actes que le ministre de la Justice ne
veut pas voir impuni aucune cause ne
justifie que des crétins décérébrés
viennent brûler une juridiction c'était
le pire endroit et le pire moment pour
pousser à fond sa Ferrari un champ de
maïs fauché du Texas par 46 degrés et ce
youtubeur américain va vite s'en rendre
compte
la paille a pris feu avec elle son
bolide à 400000 dollars et le mini vanne
de location
le vidéaste affirme qu'il s'agit d'un
accident et non pas d'une mise en scène
après l'intervention des pompiers ne lui
reste plus qu'un petit souvenir de sa
voiture
une hôtesse de l'air casque de
protection sur la tête elle est en train
de contenir un potentiel départ de feu
d'un téléphone en plein vol frayeur des
passagers
quand la batterie de mon voisin a pris
feu le Stewart a été incroyablement
rapide courageux efficace ses collègues
aussi
l'incident a eu lieu il y a une semaine
dans un avion Air France à 330 comme
celui-ci il reliés Paris à Accra au
Ghana je voulais vous montrer une image
à qui mes pattes je suis complètement
bluffée c'est un téléphone voilà un
téléphone portable alors comme ça de
prime abord on dirait une vieille Game
Boy mais en fait c'est une super
invention c'est un jeune garçon un
adolescent de 16 ans qui a créé ce
téléphone portable il s'appelle Gabriel
il va entrer en terminale dans quelques
jours et la particularité de ce
téléphone c'est qu'il a coûté moins de
30 euros pour être fabriqué au-dessus de
Casablanca de la fumée s'échappe d'un
téléphone le personnel enfile
immédiatement des équipements de
protection
il plonge l'appareil dans un sac d'eau
comme celui-ci
les personnes naviguant sont entraînés
pour gérer cette situation donc on peut
retrouver plusieurs applications donc il
y a contact message téléphone map
horloge calculatrice c'est des
applications essentielles les
simplicistes qui permettent de réaliser
les fonctions principales d'un téléphone
donc ça reste un téléphone c'est pas
forcément smartphone alors ça c'est la
version de base parce que maintenant
Gabriel est en train
train de créer donc il y aura internet
là faudra compter une bonne cinquantaine
d'euros pour le fabriquer l'incident a
été évité car sur d'autres vols des
téléphones ont déjà pris feu ici à
Barcelone en 2018 le pilote et même
forcé d'atterrir en urgence et évacuer
les passagers un incident rare Air
France ne recense que deux événements
similaires l'an dernier
et le but sur le long terme et bah c'est
de livrer des kits aux gens voilà des
kits qui fonctionneront comme ça pour
qu'on puisse les assembler chez nous
donc autant vous dire que c'est quand
même économique un téléphone portable
pour quelques dizaines d'euros moi je
dis pas non et puis c'est aussi
écologique parce que le cadre du
téléphone est fabriqué en France et a
beaucoup moins de composantes
électroniques que dans un smartphone
classique
images
les images arrivent dans quelques
instants dans ce qu'elle traverse le
périphérique on les a
est-ce qu'elles sont prêtes le temps
pour moi de vous raconter une petite
blague pète et répète sont dans un
bateau pète tombe à l'eau qui est-ce qui
reste cette question a été posée au
président Macron écoutez sa réponse si
pète est tombé à l'eau il ne reste plus
que répète sur le bateau évidemment mais
bon j'espère qu'ils avaient des gilets
de sauvetage parce que la sécurité c'est
important même pour les blagues quelle
est la différence entre un renard et il
ne peut ni voler
merci beaucoup de votre accueil merci
merci est-ce qu'on est prêt alors je
vais demander l'heure à Calogero bonsoir
Calogero
j'ai une vanne sur les matchs la fête
tout de suite qu'il existe trois types
de personnes ceux qui savent compter et
ceux qui savent pas compter
je vous laisse un peu de temps pour chez
vous
ça me laisse bouche
moi j'aime bien avoir un gros bide comme
ça à la rentrée je trouve ça pas mal
c'est magnifique on est plus d'un avoir
un gros bide à la rentrée
s'il vous plaît vous arrêtez de ricaner
merci est-ce que c'est qu'un journaliste
son livre non c'est c'est comme un
militaire un soldat sans fusil oui c'est
à dire Stan officier
comme un footballeur par exemple comme
un nageur sans palme bon florent
Manaudou est-ce que tu sais qui c'est un
youtubeur
olympique un champion de natation
olympique en France enfin Marseille ou
franche je sais pas mais en tout cas
c'est un très grand champion selon un
incontournable d'Hervé Vilard
qu'est-ce qui est fini
la vie
on ne lui souhaite pas bien entendu
capri
c'est fini